we're members at their digital
technology group here in the computer
laboratory and we work on a whole range
of computer science and engineering
problems most of the projects involve
smartphones in some way and there's a
little gang of us who are also quite
keen on drones and we have hexacopters
new quadcopter ISM and fixed-wing
aircraft and some time last year we
decided to be trying to collide these
worlds together and we would see if we
could make a fully autonomous drone
aircraft with a smartphone as the pure
source of all guidance control
navigation computes and everything else
so I'll show you captain boots which is
the name of our app that can fly a
fixed-wing aircraft this is our
graphical user interface and as you can
see it looks like a normal artificial
horizon indicator that you'd see in an
aircraft so the phone contains
everything that you need in order to
control an aircraft so we've got
accelerometers gyroscopes barometer
compass there's GPS there's plenty of
computational power there's multiple
radios the phone can work out its roll
pitch and yaw and we can then use that
to control an aircraft in order to fly
straight and level or turn onto a
certain bank and go to a certain GPS
Waypoint and so on pitching is when
you're rocking backwards and forwards
like this rolling is when you're tipping
to the sides like this and your is what
would normally be your compass heading
so it's your your your magnetic compass
heading the phone can detect all of
those aspects the trick is then how we
pass information to the plane itself in
order to fly there are multiple ways we
can pass information out of the
smartphone but the one we decided to go
for was the headphone jack
horrible buzzing noise you can hear
that's the music that flies the plane so
we chose to pipe control messages
straight down the headphone jack what
you can hear there is the control
messages so normally the kind of thing
that comes down headphone jack is some
music them beautiful combination of
sines and cosines waves that's some
symphony or some rock music or whatever
you're listening to the messages that go
down electrical cables to control servos
which are these little motors that turn
the control surfaces of the wing they're
very very simple electrical signals that
look like this
they're just square waves that are they
certain periodicity and in order to
determine how far you want this thing to
turn you send either very narrow pulses
or very broad pulses and depending on
whether you're spending narrow or broad
the motor either turns a little bit or
it turns a lot so there are ample
buzzing you can hear coming from the
phone is the audio representation of
these square waves and so that's all we
needed to do to fly the plane there's a
left and right headphone jack and we
have left and right control surfaces so
we only need two channels of control to
fly it DeltaWing glider like this and
although the governs we've got in here
we've got a normal receiver so that I
can fly the plane manually to a safe
height that's what this guy is doing
this is a buddy box this little blue guy
that allows me to switch between myself
flying the aircraft and the smartphone
flying the aircraft so that's a real
safety feature so I can always take back
control and this board here is just an
amplifier board those who can't scream
loudly enough to fly the aircraft you
want to get one volt across their
headphone jack and we need three to five
volts
to make these servos turn so this little
board here is a multiplexer board that
allows us to both step up the volume but
it also allows us to multiplex extra
channels so normally this would just be
left and right and we'd only have two
channels of control of the aircraft and
that's actually all we're using at the
moment but we built a board that allows
us to turn the two channels we get out
of the smartphone into four channels of
control we do that by being a little bit
more clever with our square waves so
normally you'd be sending these pulses
between Norton one volts but what we
realized we could do is send some square
wave pulses
at 1/2 a vault and a whole separate
family going the other way so we're
sending very complicated signal which an
op-amp on board our multiplexer board
can unpick these two and it can have
this one stepped up between norton 1
volts and it could take this bottom one
which is also just going naught and half
of all its depth at it between 1 volts
as well so we end up kind of dividing
each channel into two and splitting them
up so only two channels coming out of
the smartphone but with an even more
complicated square wave going on and
this board of op amps we can unpick four
channels so that would mean in the
future we could have the motor control
being controlled by a smartphone and a
fourth channel as well so we could move
to a quadcopter say we can have four
channels of control for the full props
on a quadcopter which would be quite
cool so for safety reasons I always
maintain control of the motor
even when buzz is flying the plane and
mostly buzz just glides the plane unless
we're having him do acrobatics like
bloop loops in which case I will
maintain full throttle but when he
doesn't need to be on full throttle I
pull it back but we do have the
capability to allow him to take control
of the motor himself it's just a safety
thing we haven't done that and he
doesn't need to because he glides very
well so we take him up to a safe height
I so I can fly the plane with this
controller we take him up to a safe
height I then flick the switch and
captain Birds is running on a smartphone
underneath the aircraft we mount a cover
underneath to protect the phone and when
I'm not find a plane captain buzzes so
as you can see at the moment captain
bezu sets to try to maintain straight
and level flight so as I rock the plane
to a strong angle like this the
smartphone has detected that it's on a
very strong role and has commanded that
it needs this wing to drop and this wing
to come back up that's why I like
control surface is very high and as the
aircraft does roll back the two control
surfaces will come to the same level
there's still a little bit of a life we
reckon about 100 milliseconds of lag but
this was the biggest challenge when we
first started doing this project the lag
was 250 milliseconds and that meant that
this aircraft were loaded around the sky
like a pregnant duck
it didn't really fly like a fighter jet
it's much more responsive now and it's
much more responsive now because Olli
one of the PhD students here in the lab
did some impressive work on reducing the
latency and understanding where the
latency is coming from so anyone can buy
quad copters and and drones that have
some level of autonomy they either
maintain a safe bank angle or they
return home back to the GPS fix if they
lose the radio link and things like this
so there's all of these levels of
autonomy that you can buy off the shelf
but the computers on board that do those
tasks are very very simple and they just
do those simple tasks very very well
very very quickly but they can't be
expanded to all sorts of new cool stuff
so one of the reasons we thought we
would see if you could do all of this
with a smartphone there's not just
because it's quite cool to disrupt the
pair of wings onto a smartphone and
throw it out the window and have you
smartphone fly around but it was to look
at all of the next things you could do
once we've done this first layer which
is just get the thing flying sensibly
between GPS waypoints and Staveley so we
can make use of the cameras underneath
we could do a navigation system based on
optical flow of the scenery passing
underneath as opposed to based on the
GPS coordinates there's a huge amount of
processing power and there's lots of
radio communication capability that we
can tap into next and we could do some
quite cool things to demonstrate the
utility of smartphone based drones so
for example in the real a V Asian world
there are systems called T casts and a
DSB that it's do with understanding
where aircraft are and preventing
collisions so one of those systems is
based on radio and your GPS position
around to other aircraft which is
trivial to do when you've got GPS on
board and the cellular network or Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth another one is a much
simpler system which is literally just
proximity based and the aircraft is
warned that there's another aircraft on
a collision course
and of course with Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
in smartphones again it's trivial these
these these smartphones have this aura
around them they have their Wi-Fi bubble
and the bluetooth bubble and we could
trivially have a bunch of drones flying
around the sky that are all turning away
from any other Bluetooth or Wi-Fi source
well we could easily make this go and
find Wi-Fi Bluetooth sources so it could
fly over a region and map out where all
the wi-fi's are underneath so we're
really interested in some of the cool
stuff we can do next now that we saw the
problem just getting a smartphone to fly
itself
we'd like to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring this episode of computerphile
you can get building your website today
go to Squarespace comm / computer Val
and there's a chance to get 10% off so
check out that website there trusted by
millions and they use by some of the
world's most respected brands so get
over to Squarespace comm / computerphile
start building today you don't even need
to put your credit card details in and
some of you computer files might want to
check out the developers area developers
squarespace.com thanks once again to
them for sponsoring this computerphile
video
you